♪ (piano) ♪
- Le Musée des beaux-arts
de l'Ontario se couvre de bleu
à l'occasion d'une exposition
unique en son genre.
"Picasso: Painting The Blue
Period" est la première
exposition au Canada
à se concentrer uniquement
sur le début de carrière
de Pablo Picasso.
Peintes entre 1901 et 1904,
ces oeuvres monochromes offrent
un nouvel éclairage sur
l'état d'esprit du grand maître
espagnol et permettent d'entrer
dans la tête d'un jeune Picasso.
"Plusieurs oublient que
Picasso n'avait que 20 ans
quand la période bleue
a débuté", rappelle
le commissaire d'exposition.
Parmi les thèmes récurrents
de la période bleue, on retrouve
la pauvreté, la misère et
la charité, avec une inspiration
marquée de l'art religieux.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais l'exposition présentée
par l'AGO ne se distingue pas
uniquement par les thèmes qui
y sont représentés, mais aussi
par la méthodologie entreprise
par le musée. Car en plus
de recueillir 94 oeuvres signées
par Picasso, l'AGO a soumis
trois de ces tableaux à
une examination par infrarouge,
qui a permis de découvrir
les brouillons sous
ces peintures marquantes.
"De voir qu'ils ont trouvé
une peinture sous la peinture,
c'est fascinant!",
lance cette Torontoise.
Ce travail minutieux aura pris
sept ans. Et l'exposition est
presque tombée à l'eau en raison
de la pandémie et des nombreux
contrats de prêt qu'il a fallu
renégocier.
"C'est toute une chance,
on risque de ne plus pouvoir
revoir ses tableaux",
souligne cette fan de Picasso.
L'exposition sera présentée
à l'AGO jusqu'au 16 janvier.
Après Toronto, ce sera au tour
du musée Phillips Collection
de Washington d'accueillir
la collection et de, lui aussi,
se couvrir de bleu.
Ici Yasmine Medhi,
Radio-Canada, Toron